I wish I just had a rayleota podcast I
would talk about Ray Liotta all [__]
day good okay I would the Rayleigh yeah
because he's done enough films that you
could actually make one he's done films
yeah
smoking Ace that would actually be a
great podcast going through every Ray
Liotta film that no one's seen
um I'm not gonna get back and we're
venturing back into rayload I'm not
going to do that but I'm saying there's
that dude on Reddit who did like a mega
thread where he watched a hundred Nick
Cage movies yeah there's a lot of them
yeah he rated them all it's a lot of
waste of time yeah
hey [__] you watch Amadeus four
times three days ago
I had no power in my house yeah how was
that I had no power amount it was cold
yeah it's very cold no power at my house
so I downloaded Amadeus was this story
this is like about three and a half
hours long film and I did watch it four
times I guess I love that movie and with
the power out you were essentially like
sitting on an airplane for multiple days
so yeah except I was laying down on a
couch yeah just watching Amadeus
it's a great movie how are you charging
things if you didn't have any power I
set out my truck
I'd sit out my truck and I would charge
my phone and the iPads and stuff
because you have to watch Amadeus so you
need to charge that stuff because it's
like you get like
one viewing of Amadeus off of iPad yeah
so go back and charge it charge it up
maybe a couple drives it went around and
did some driving stuff charged the phone
listened to some
Mozart in the car just to get yourself
prepared for the second viewing of
Amadeus right and then you go in and
then you watch it again yeah and then
repeat the cycle and then you um you
just shoot a gun like kind of in this
area so you blow out your hearing on one
side and then that gets you ready for
the third viewing of Amadeus that's uh I
think you're mistaking that for
Beethoven because the Beethoven the
Beethoven's the deaf one oh got it well
what can I say you should watch Amadeus
that's what you should that's what you
should say actually we've seen Amadeus
no when you mention that it's all
natural lighting that really piqued my
Curiosities It's A Beautiful film I want
to watch it it's very good yeah you guys
have you seen Amadeus no okay
I'm just waiting for you to get real
I'm pretty sure I just got real by
saying that I watched Amadeus four times
oh my [__] I don't think this is my song
by the way
Luke is like trying to antagonize you he
does this man it's crazy he was never
like this the first like six months to a
year where he's gotten too comfortable
it's not even too comfortable what is
that what I can't it's distracting me
too much what the hell is that
whatever you want what I mean like why
what what is it I need to know I've been
dancing around the whole time I keep
like I was joking about Chantix and
every once in a while my eyes are Dart
over real quick like that got it and
then what the hell is that why is it
there do you want the full meta on what
it is kind of okay the mannequin piece
is from the short Kings Anthem music
video okay and I'm a when it comes to
creative work I'm a big like hoarder
okay so I'm like do you like saying all
your set pieces and all that yeah yeah
so we kept that and then
at some point someone said maybe we
should put some clothes on her and so
that's like a TMG t-shirt and then the
hat and the top uh are from like a bit
we did where we wore a ghillie suit okay
so now it just looks like
now it's just this [__]
a humanoid thing well have you seen any
new movies lately I haven't honestly
because the tour I've just been
literally when is it gonna be done I
know I've brought this up before May
29th yeah May 20th that's it yeah that
is the end no more I can't say no more I
mean like I mean like for this one yeah
yeah no more cheeky things where it's
just like uh oh I added dates no if I
see that on my [__] Instagram again
no I'm gonna throw myself out a window
no no no cheeky eight dates especially
with what me and you got going on
transition huh
huh that was slick dude well guys girls
whatever you are
um if there's any girls listening to
this turn get the [__] off right now
I'm not having it actually
uh on that note we have an extremely
woman friendly project coming out it's
our new podcast the stretch and fade
podcast I want to call it stretch marks
and Fades but they got rid of the marks
yeah it's just wordy
it's a lot yeah I yeah it's a good news
we know you know you're used to putting
a lot in your mouth but well sure that's
why I had the stretch marks yeah
not not so much for the rest of us um
should we have promoted this at the top
fine now I mean
the viewers are gone yeah if people if
people were able to Traverse the Ray
Liotta part of the section of this
podcast that I think they're gonna be
prime candidates for our our podcast
yeah the Ray Liotta discussion was to
weed anyone out yeah yeah if people were
like what the [__] is this this Ray
Liotta [__] they turn it off and
other people are like I'm fascinated
yeah those are the people I wanted I'm
now you got me thinking if there's
people in the car like yeah but [__]
really just turning it up yes
there's a lot of wrecks that probably
happened because people got it so
excited I [__] hate rake
driving in bashing people they probably
people also took up smoking because of
this podcast yeah dude and that's kind
of cool too yeah the sheer stress of
having to think about Ray Liotta that
much just the sheer stress of being like
I need to be like Ray yeah and that's
what uh if you do end up taking smoking
please go on Twitter and tag me have you
smoking cigarettes anyway
uh we have a new podcast coming out and
um here's a little trailer for that
[Music]
and here you are one Code Zero you know
uh a couple birdies
told me that you might know where the
James Corden sex tape's at
is that true
come on man
well I do
he's incredibly dangerous
and if you want that tape you're gonna
have to come with all you got well I'd
get up everything to see that monster of
a man
I was way through a sex tape
his name
everyone wants that tape just know that
he is heavily armed and he is incredibly
dangerous
bingo
[Music]
clean up your hands of James corden's
sex tape
go easy on them
every time
they try me every time
[Music]
[Applause]
you lose Timothy chalamet
how about you flip your cute ass out of
here and never return
thanks
oh God damn
oh he actually did it Jesus Christ
nice
that man's got good hips damn good hips
and his girlfriend's happy okay
the sign says no smoking [__]
easy
but the character
give us a James Corden [__] tape [__]
I want to watch it [__] you who's your
fat friend hey
it's Mr Fatty Magoo to you rat
my name is
here James
so yes that's why I'm here this is mine
how big is his deck
not only your [__] business pizza boy
don't make us hurt you rat give us the
[__] DVD get us a [__] kill me to
get this
go ahead
Blow Me Away
[Music]
foreign
just in time for love and confection
this is the last time you miss a stretch
and fade
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa whoa could you have
gotten a smaller shirt for me on the set
no
I didn't I know that it's it's nice and
silly seeing the big guy in a tight
shirt right we all laughed but uh I
actually did I didn't ask for that I
said I'm very uncomfortable on set and
no I was just like just do it dude yeah
just do it you're slowing everything
down yeah I'm like you're already stink
don't be slow as well
ah the feet is up people can go
subscribe oh yeah uh go so go look up
the the show stretch and fade podcast
it's on Spotify Apple podcast wherever
you get your podcast it's also gonna be
here and it'll be in the TMG Studios app
ad free
you still thinking about it I don't know
I don't know what to say yeah well you
know I want it there
you want to hear do you want this again
no come on did you have a good time
listening to this one no come on the the
four episodes you've had so far
genuinely were
very funny you say some crazy stuff
yeah it's wacky it is wacky is it pretty
wacky yeah so tune into the podcast uh
it's gonna be a lot of fun
um Hunter is not always so sarcastic and
down on himself
um there's he smiles sometimes too I
smile a lot I've smiled a lot during the
show yeah